you tonight new information in regards
to a dog sitting facility in the
northeast valley that recently came
under fire well it turns out that
charges have been filed after a woman
says her dog died there this past summer
joe moeller is live near nellis and lake
mead with what we've learned more about
this case joe
8 news now first shared the story of a
family who says their dog died just days
after coming back from this facility
after a stay here while another woman
who was an animal rights advocate says
charges have now been filed after a
different death
[Music]
animal rights advocate gina greison says
a rescue dog she took in named maura was
being boarded at paz sitter in july for
several days she says she got a text
that maura died and a necropsy
determined to die from heat stroke the
district attorney's office tells me
animal cruelty charges were filed
against victor garcia herrera in
connection with morris death at paz we
trusted this boarding facility which i
understood a lot of rescues use
to take good care of these dogs and
to lose a dog like that and and and see
the condition that she was kept in and
they could you know that had lost so
much weight and
i mean i just couldn't believe that like
you know how we found her the charges
come days after eight news now shared
the story about another dog canna the
atencio family says they picked up the
dog in a sick condition and the dog died
days after it came home the owner tells
us they filed a complaint with animal
control to our knowledge no necropsy was
done
the family of khanna did not or did file
a report with animal control i reached
out to garcia herrera for response on
both of these cases and we did not get a
response from them he's due in court
early next month reporting live in the
northeast valley joe muller live local
now